usa la fórmula cuadrática para resolver
la ecuación - x cuadrada + 8 x igual a 1
y bueno lo que dice la fórmula
cuadrática es que las ecuaciones de la
forma
x cuadrada más bx más c esto igualado a
cero tienen como solución x igual a
menos b más menos la raíz cuadrada de b
cuadrada menos cuatro veces a poseen
todo esto está dentro de la raíz
cuadrada y esto dividido entre dos veces
a todo esto dividido entre dos veces amp
y bueno esta es una fórmula muy
importante que algún día te debes de
aprender porque la vamos a ocupar
bastante cuando veamos matemáticas ahora
lo que quiero que veas es que aquí
tenemos la ecuación en su posición
estándar porque está igualada 0 y
tenemos los términos de x ordenados de
exponente mayor exponente menor y si te
das cuenta el problema aquí es que no lo
tenemos igualado a cero y entonces para
poner en su forma estándar lo que voy a
hacer es restar menos 1
ambos lados de la ecuación menos 1 de
este lado y menos 1 también de este lado
entonces que voy a obtener menos x
cuadrada
después más 8x
y después -1 aquí nada se puede
simplificar y del otro lado que me queda
menos uno más uno se va
esto me da cero y bueno entonces ahora
si ya lo tengo en la forma estándar si
te das cuenta tengo ya igualado a cero
esta ecuación cuadrática y además tengo
primero lo que tiene que ver con x
cuadrada después lo que tiene que ver
con x después lo que tiene que ver con
la constante y esto igualado a cero
entonces aquí ya puedo saber varias
cosas ya puedo decir que a vale menos
uno a vale menos uno porque es el
coeficiente que está al lado de la x
cuadrada el coeficiente que está al lado
de la x cuadrada si te das cuenta que
tenemos menos x cuadrada - x cuadrada
pues es lo mismo que tener menos 1 x
cuadrada recuerda que cuando tenemos
menos x cuadrada es lo mismo que tener
menos 1 por x cuadrada porque la
multiplicación por 1 es lo mismo y
entonces me queda que vale menos 1 este
de aquí perfecto y después yo tengo más
bx y aquí entonces me dice que me vale 8
es este 8 que tengo aquí este de aquí es
lo que vale
pues para finalizar a esto le tengo que
sumar ser más pero cuánto vales en esta
ocasión se vale menos uno con todo el
signo es muy importante tomar todos
estos valores con todo y signo sea el
valor de la constante que vale menos 1
entonces ahora sí ya que tengo el valor
de amd b y c voy a aplicar la fórmula
cuadrática para saber cuáles son las
raíces de esta ecuación cuadrática
entonces que voy a obtener vamos a
cambiar x es igual a quien a menos b
pero me vale 8 entonces déjame ponerlo
con el color debe menos 8 más menos más
menos vamos a hacerlo con mucho cuidado
la raíz cuadrada de b cuadrada pero ve
vale 8 entonces es la raíz cuadrada de 8
elevado al cuadrado ya esto le tengo que
quitar menos 4 veces hace menos 4 veces
a que vale menos 1 entonces vámonos al
color de a esto por menos 1 por c pero
se vale también menos 1 entonces esto
multiplicado también por menos 1 y a
todo esto hay que dividirlo entre dos
veces a entonces 2 que multiplica a
menos 12 x menos 1 y bueno esto quién es
igual vamos a hacerlo esto es lo mismo
que quien tengo x es igual a menos 8 es
este 8 de aquí más menos la raíz
cuadrada de quien de 8 al cuadrado lo
cual de 64 menos 4 por 14 menos por
menos me da más x menos me da menos
vamos bien aquí cuatro por una por una
me da cuatro ya todo esto lo tengo que
dividir entre dos por menos uno lo cual
me da menos dos y esto por cierto a
cuánto es igual a menos ocho más menos
la raíz cuadrada de quien voy a
simplificar lo que está aquí adentro 64
menos 4 me da 60 y a todo esto lo tengo
que dividir entre menos 2
perfecto pero aquí el problema es que 60
no tiene raíz cuadrada exacta por lo
tanto lo que se me ocurre es que podemos
simplificar un poco esta raíz factor
izando al número 60 que me quedarían 60
60 a su vez tiene mitad y la mitad de 60
es 30 30 30 su vestido y mitad y la
mitad de 30 es 15 15 15 sub extiende
tercera la tercera de 15 es 5 date
cuenta que 15 jan tiene mitad por eso
saque tercera y bueno 5 ya no tiene
mitad ya no tiene tercera lo único que
tiene es quinta por lo tanto podemos
escribir la raíz de 60 de esta forma
como la raíz de dos por dos por tres por
cinco
y esto quién es pues esto es lo mismo
que tomarme la raíz de dos por dos
y después tomarme la raíz de 3 por 5
porque la raíz cumple esta propiedad que
se puede dividir cuando los que están
adentro están multiplicándose y eso es
igual a la raíz de 2 por 2 que es la
raíz de 4 lo cual es 2 y ahí después
tengo la raíz de 3 por 5 en lo cual no
se puede simplificar y entonces lo voy a
poner como la raíz de 15 y bueno
entonces esto me da pie a que esta
expresión de aquí la pueda poner la
siguiente manera esto es lo mismo que
tener menos 8 más menos la raíz cuadrada
de quien de 60 pero 60 es lo mismo que
dos veces la raíz de 15 entonces más
menos 2 veces la raíz de 15 y todo esto
dividido entre -2 y aquí ya tengo mis
dos posibles resultados y me tomo esta
expresión con signo positivo y esta
expresión con signo negativo pero bueno
nos hemos quedado sin espacio así que
para obtener la respuesta correcta
déjenme mover un poco esta pantalla para
que yo pueda ser un poco más despacio y
entonces así terminar este problema que
me va a quedar
es igual a quien a menos 8 más menos 2
veces la raíz cuadrada de 15 entre -2 y
bueno pues esto me da pie a pensar en
mis dos soluciones mi primera solución
nueva queda de la siguiente manera x es
igual a menos 8 más me voy a tomar el
primer signo que es el signo positivo
dos veces la raíz de 15 esto entre menos
2 este es mi primer solución si me tomo
el primer signo del signo positivo y por
otra parte tengo que x es igual a menos
8 menos dos veces la raíz de 15
todo esto dividido entre menos 2 aquí
tengo me dio otra raíz porque tiene ya
el signo negativo y entonces estoy
separando estos dos signos en una
primera raíz con el signo positivo y en
la segunda raíz con signo negativo pero
qué crees date cuenta que esto que
tenemos aquí es lo mismo que quien voy a
dividir este entre este y que me va a
quedar me queda menos 8 entre menos 2 lo
cual me da 4 positivo menos entre menos
me da más 8 entre 24 y después tengo
esto de acá que es más entre menos me da
menos 2 entre 2 se van y solamente me
queda la raíz de 15 raíz de 15 esta es
mi primera solución y primera raíz y por
otro lado tengo esa expresión que tengo
aquí y que me queda pues voy a hacer lo
mismo voy a dividir primero estos dos y
tengo menos entre menos me da más 8
entre 24 y por otra parte tengo estos 2
y estos dos que me quedan menos 2 y
menos dos se cancelan y solamente me
queda más la raíz de 15 ya que está ya
lo hemos logrado tengo aquí mis dos
raíces de ésta
cuadrática que fue con la que empecé que
está aquí arriba y entonces ya sé que si
yo pongo estas dos raíces que acabo de
encontrar en esta ecuación entonces voy
a encontrar que estas dos una solución
de esta ecuación cuadrática